Now, that you've wrapped your head
around what the Firebase UI is actually
doing, let's pop it into our code.
Here the general steps that I've laid
out to get things up and running.
I've taken the liberty of already
doing steps two and three for you.
There's already an mListView
object in the code for you.
And I've also made an XML layout
called single_ active_ list.
You've actually already used
this layout to display one list.
Also, that describes in greater
detail how to do all this stuff.
The most complicated slash interesting
part is in the fire-based list adapter.
There's this method called PopulateView,
which is meant to be overwritten.
PopulateView is a method that
supplies two key arguments.
First is a view that is
the inflated version
of the layout that you gave
the adapter upon creation.
It also gives you a POJO, which in
this case, will be a Shopping List.
It's then your job to take this view,
grab the sub text views,
images views, and whatever else
there is in the layout, and
then, appropriately fill
it with data from the POJO.
Okay, I'll send over the spec now so
that you can add Firebase UI
to Shopping List Plus Plus.